so what's been the biggest challenge of  running your own YouTube channel the  biggest challenge was belief that I  could do it belief that my message was  worthy that somebody would want to hear  from me that my story mattered the  biggest fight I would get into with my  agent was him just telling me that I  need to be famous like I don't want to  be famous dude Steve I don't want to be  famous like it was years of fighting  with him you know he's helped blowing up  Mel Robbins and Grant Cardone and some  other pretty big names and in thought  leadership education and it wasn't until  he said but the more people who know you  the more people will hear the message